des socialistes unis et qui veulent y
croire
lors de cette ultime réunion commune à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines montée du fn abstention deux
facteurs que les binômes candidat espère
endiguer
alors que vient le moment de faire le
bilan de la campagne du premier tour des
départementales moment ça se termine on
se dit toujours mais qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu faire encore qu'est ce qu'on
n'a pas fait voilà non la campagne s'est
bien passé bien déroulé bon accueil on
sent évidemment que les électeurs sont
il borde pas de motivation donc faut
vraiment y aller et aujourd'hui on sent
vraiment une cagnotte
un mouvement un peu plus important qu'il
ya quelques semaines sur la
participation et c'est quelque chose que
justement on essaie de combattre leur
fils l'abstention qui s'annonce et qui
peut être important mais qui s'annonçait
plus massif que ça il ya quelques temps
déjà
le message principal c'est de dire aux
électeurs à aller voter et ne vous
trompez pas de combat en votes pour le
département la venue apporter son
soutien le président de la région ile de
france jean paul huchon connaît bien les
yvelines lui qui a officié en tant que
maire de conflans-sainte-honorine de
1994 à 2001 il sait que le département a
toujours été difficile pour les
socialistes nous peu loin d'une défaite
sanglante
moi je voyais beaucoup de militants sur
le terrain je viens de maisons laffitte
de sartrouville pas des villes a priori
gagnable immédiatement palais social
il ya quand même un vrai puncheur a
retenu ce militant un jean paul huchon
également candidat à la primaire du ps
pour les régionales de décembre le 28
mai il sera fixé sur son sort les
instances trancheront et jugeront si
elles l'estiment capable de décrocher un
quatrième mandat